[Music]
let's talk about red - you also worked
with mr. John Malkovich a fantastic
actor you guys you get a car chase scene
for many days in Paris we were in the
car for many hours and then at the end
of I think they have a clip because we
did something which I don't know if it's
in the movie or not because I haven't
seen the movie but there was at the end
of the car scene Bruce and I thought it
would be John Malkovich in you John
Malkovich and I thought that it would be
a cool idea to since we had been hit
from behind and the car had been
spinning from the front we thought that
it would be a great idea to projectile
vomit at the end of the tape so we were
in Paris so they got win over the
walking they were like can we get some
vomit and from Earth arose and drawn a
corner to vote they went to a cafe I can
hear any of that by the way they want to
get fake vomit yeah
so they got french toast soaked in milk
and we yeah and then you put that in
your mouth and you this was so you could
fake vomit did you brought a clip of
this I brought it I don't know if
they're going to show it
we'll show it you know why not yeah we
have this place let's take a look at
this clip of you this is a we don't know
if this is in the movie or not so it may
not have I'm fairly certain it's not in
the movie
okay so this is a sneak peek at a scene
you'll never see
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty foul I see why they cut it they
cut it because it just looks like you're
spitting french toast you do because it
can't all be Bruce Willis firing a gun
into your face we have a clip here a
real clip this is a clip from red -
that's a theme of the day where he shot
the bean okay let's take a look at this
scene from where he shot to be from red
- but you don't see the B part it's
crazy
Daniel's OC
[Music]
some of the stuff you just can't teach
Pussycats right Frank oh come on what
did you get Marvin you gave her a gun it
is America Frank everyone else has a gun
no idea what toys
[Applause]